[Music]
nearly the entirety of the story of
ursula k le guin second earth sea novel
the tombs of ottawa is set on that
island in the kargish lands and if we
count the waters around it in the last
chapter we can say that the entirety of
the story is set there
which means that we should talk about
the the nature of these lands
and its society and we got introduced to
them
very briefly in two ways in the earlier
novel a wizard of earthsea where
uh ged the the young
soon-to-be mage who winds up being a
main character in this story as well
living on gantt his island is invaded by
kargish
warriors who are there to to pillage to
to take to kill
and perhaps to
enslave the occupants of the island
later on on the island of roque we find
that the master neymar is himself a karg
he's got a very long name that doesn't
actually mean anything and that's all
that we really get about those people
set on these islands way to the
north and and east
uh in in the archipelago who have their
own distinct way of life and are set
apart from the
rest of the archipelago there there are
differences of course uh oscar to the
north is a different kind of place than
you know some of the southern uh islands
let alone pandora to the west but the
kargish lands are really
their own thing and ursula k le guin
in conversations and and writings about
this says well you know i didn't do much
with them in the first novel and then i
decided i'd set the second novel
there so it's distinct from the rest of
earth see it's set apart
as four main islands
corrego art where the power center is
which is also the
west most and so you know raiding
parties can go out from there quite
easily ottawa where the main action
takes place in this story very close to
corrego at and then further
north and east of these are her ather
and anini you notice that there's a
repeated term
in each of these the oct things so
that's part of their language we don't
actually get much of their language just
a few
name places and names of people
and words in this so it's not as if
leguin is world building in that way but
she does tell us an awful lot
about their viewpoints there is you
could say a world within the world of
earth sea that consists in the kargish
lands
part of this has to do with ethnicity
so
leguin made a deliberate decision when
thinking out earthsea to make the
majority of the archipelago non-white
people
race doesn't have the same import
in her world that it often does in ours
but different people have different skin
colors so vetch is nearly black
get is described as having a copper tone
to his skin
even the people that are quite
light-skinned are sallow or yellowish
for example
sarat the sorcerer the sorceress on gant
and then up in oscar
the people on the kargash islands are
very very light-skinned and you know one
of them
the friend of arja is described as like
turning cheery red when she engages in
exertion from the blood going to her her
face so there's their skin color and the
um inhabitants of the kargish lands
distrust the dark people they don't
distress them because they're dark they
distress them for all sorts of other
reasons as we're going to talk about
language the kargs have their own
distinct language which they know and
very few people outside of their
territories know and they generally
don't speak the languages of the rest of
earth sea
whether it's the main tongue that's
that's spoken there which is descended
from the old tongue or any of the other
dialects that are
used among people so that's something
that sets them apart and they have a
very negative view
of non-cargs part of this could be the
typical
ethnocentrism that we see in almost all
peoples right but it also stems from as
we learn their history
and a view of people from what they call
the inner lands the inner lands being
all the rest of earth see
as engaging in things that are unsavory
dark arts
forbidden arts
things that are not
all right to do
and so
one of these is magic
there are no wizards or witches or
sorcerers or anything like that as a
matter of fact what we see when the one
of the greatest of of mages is there
ereth akba
is he's not opposed by a wizard he is
opposed by a high priest and it's
wizardry versus the gods
not wizardry versus wizardry so
the kargish people they have a very
complex and kind of you know developing
you could say over time religion but
they they don't use sorcery they're set
apart from the rest of earth sea by that
and they view people who who do use
sorcery as you know very bad people
same thing with writing it's it's talked
about by our as a black art it's
something accursed that you don't really
use so all of the things that they're
memorizing they are keeping up in their
minds sort of like the the mages who
study at earthsea although there's a
library there as well
and at one point get actually tells are
you know the art of writing is in fact
very useful that's how i found out how
to get into the tombs and you know
how to avoid the problems that other
people ran into
there's also a difference in how they
view life and death
this is really fundamental this is going
to be
more or less just referenced here
or assumed and then explained much more
in the later
earthsea volumes
kargs when they die
don't believe and in reality don't go to
the dry land they are
reincarnated they are born again
as another person in the case of arja
it's a priestess who is reborn in bodies
over and over again through
millennia
in the case of others for example
penthouse says oh i have to be a
priestess in this life i don't like that
hopefully i can be a dancing girl next
time around you know and i'll get to
live a little bit right so they have a
very different attitude about life and
death
we don't
think in the story that they still have
any dragons left in
the kargish lands although they may have
had some in the past
and in place of the use of magic
religious rituals
and
beliefs
also centered on temples and a hierarchy
play a central role
in carcass life the religious
sites could be used as places for truces
places to consult the gods that's how
ottowan becomes such an important place
for the cult of the nameless ones and so
what we've got represented until the
11th chapter
is this you know very different uh
religiously haunted land which is
hostile to outsiders and
goes and raids them now how did things
wind up like that well there's there's a
backstory and there's a present so let's
start in the present itself
we know that there is now a car god
empire
and this is why they can raid places
like gantt
and
we find that
here we go
this is discussed
uh by manan telling arha something long
ago before our four lands joined
together into an empire
before there was a god king over us
there were a lot of lesser kings princes
chiefs they were always quarreling with
each other
um and we're going to talk a little bit
about that in in a moment and then after
a while the priest kings came to rule
all of kharago at and soon they were
ruling atawan and now for four or five
lifetimes of men the god-kings have
ruled all the four lands together and
made them an empire and so things have
changed the god king can put down the
unruly chiefs settle all the corals
himself being a god he doesn't have to
consult the nameless ones very often so
what's going on there we have the rise
essentially of a theocracy right a uh
priestly
uh lineage that is also the political
rulers uniting the four kargish islands
together
and uh
if not completely
wiping out at least settling the places
and scores between
all the other
people who matter the nobility and so
the
the cult of the god king
becomes the most important religious
you know ceremonies
rulership
hierarchy within the kargish lands in
our has time and this is what allows the
priestess castle
who is the priestess of the god king
there at ottawa to
arrogate more power for herself she
actually says the nameless ones they're
old they don't have any power anymore
but what we know from this same thing is
that the nameless ones were a much more
early
religion so
as uh manan says they'd come from from
here to they'd come here to settle their
quarrels that's how it was they'd come
for our from our land atuan karego at
ottnini and even from herrera all the
chiefs and princes with their servants
and armies they'd ask you
the priestess what to do
and you'd go before the empty throne and
give them the counsel of the nameless
one so
in a divided
ethnicity a divided kingdom
set apart against the rest of the
archipelago the nameless ones and its
religion its cult
headed by a priestess had a very
important role now they are largely
neglected except at atuan itself as i
mentioned the priestess of the god king
gets to
denigrate them and that is cursed by
arha there is also a third important
religious cult that's mentioned that of
the twin brothers and as we're going to
find out the god king thing comes out of
the cult of the twin brothers who were
probably originally heroes sort of like
deified
human beings like hercules or caster and
pollux in
greek and roman and so many other things
you might think of ogun in ifa yoruba
mythology and religion you know
not not starting out as a god but
becoming a god so all of this is going
on and as some are going up others are
going down as the kingdom is becoming
more unified under those who hold power
others are
suffering because of that
there is a story of the kargish lands
being divided and being invaded by the
archipelagons this is castle and thar
telling
arha about it
this is before the god kings ruled the
kargish lands we were not so strong then
the wizards used to sail from the west
to karego ott and ottawa
to plunder the towns on the coast loot
the farms even come into the sacred city
ah
they came to kill dragons they said but
they stayed to rob towns and temples
and then thar says and their great
heroes would come among us to test their
swords and work their ungodly spells and
they tell the story
of how
one of the greatest of sorcerers aerith
aqba comes with his staff and his ring
and fights against well he gets involved
in politics in in the local politics uh
warring against each other and he winds
up trying to take
the city
and this this brings about a conflict
with the high priest in tottenham which
ends up breaking the ring which is the
pretext for the entire quest that get is
on right the central part of the story
and
over time what we see is this culture
hero this uh protector of at least his
city becomes viewed as the protector of
the land and the lineage of this high
priest in tottenham
originally a priest of the twin brothers
is going to lead to the god kings who
now have ruled the kargish lands for
four or five lifetimes so quite a long
time perhaps several hundred years
and this also leads to the destruction
of some of the other independent
kargish houses in particular that of
thorig we find out in the very end
there's the tale of ged who met up with
the
two
people on the island a third kargish
encounter you could say
and we find in towards the end of the
book um
that that thar told arha
that uh during the the time of the
priest kings
and the god kings all this time the
house of thoreg
the one that ereth akbar was associated
with uh grew poorer and weaker and so at
last thar told me there were only two of
the lineage of thorig left little
children a boy and a girl
and so the god king had them stolen from
their place and hapon didn't want to
kill them directly and so abandoned them
on an island that was little more than a
sand bar they were named ensar and anfil
and it was anthill who gave ged the
ring so there's this entire backstory
and when we learn this backstory whether
it's reliable
or not we can get a sense perhaps why
it's not just you know ethnocentrism
or you know kind of a distrust in
general
of of foreigners but there's also this
this back history
that
tells us why the kargs don't like
anybody else they don't like the people
from the inner aisles they're also kind
of mistaken about the nature of the
inner aisles and there's a really
interesting conversation
between
um
ged and
arha about that where he he fills her in
and he says that um here we go
what um
she she says that um
it would be foolish if such things went
on the raiding that's happening between
the kargish empire and the inner lands
what would the god king do with so many
slaves and gad says if the kargish lands
defeated the archipelago you mean she
nodded i don't think that's likely to
happen
but look how strong the empire is that
great city with its walls and all its
men how could your land stand up against
them if they attacked and ged says to
her
that's not a great city
i too would have thought it tremendous
when i was new for my mountain but there
are many many cities in earth sea among
which this is only a town there are many
many lands you will see them tenar and
the point there is that
the kargish lands there's an insularity
pun intended to them they don't realize
how vast what they're calling the inner
lands actually are they're one of the
you know
smaller locations
in earth sea and i would like to end by
bringing up the village that they go to
one of the things that this shows is
yes there are some vast differences
between the cards and the rest of the
people in the archipelago this is going
to raise some real issues for tenar as
she is leaving her land and going out to
you know hovnor and the rest of of earth
sea eventually she's going to settle in
gantt but what we find is that the
villagers
are really not that different from place
to place that there's a shared human
reality
ged
puts them under a glamour that hides
their their nature
the fact that he's an outsider in the
fact that she's a priestess and then
they beg for supper they left the
village the next morning with full
stomachs after a pleasant sleep in a hay
loft do mages often bag-ass tenor why do
you ask you seemed used to begging in
fact you were good at it well yes i've
begged all my life if you look at it
this way wizards don't own much you know
in fact nothing but their staff and
clothing if they wander they are
received and given food and shelter by
most people gladly they do make some
return
what return well that woman in the
village i cured her goats
what was wrong with them they both had
infected udders i used to herd goats
when i was a boy
and then she says i see your magic is
not good only for large things and then
gad says hospitality kindness to a
stranger that's a very large thing
thanks are enough of course but i was
sorry for the goats
and now notice that
the hospitality that they're enjoying is
not because he's a wizard it's precisely
because he's not viewed as a wizard that
these common people are willing even
though they don't have much to take
others in and help them out on their
journey and this helps keep life
going in in the uh entire
place so we've got this great you know
political and religious stuff on the
higher you could say elite trickle-down
level and then we end by looking at
how things are for the common people
which is where
the story actually began
with the
little girl tenar who's going to become
arja the priestess being taken from her
village being taken from her parents who
are so poor that they don't even own the
place that they
live in and farm so this gives you at
least some sense from this book of what
the kargish lands and culture are like
we're going to learn more
in
later novels and short stories of
earthsea but that's that's enough for
what we see in the tombs of ottawa
you